لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له هو يتولى
الصالحين واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
وصفيه من خلقه وخليله وامينه على وحيه
الداعي الى رضوانه اما بعد ك
الوجيز في كتاب الطهاره
سنن الفطره
سنن
سن
however
of
not
used by
of
confused so
حديثه
accين
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
was to
have did to have done or to havecknled
this is
عقيده
would
البدعه
الشرك والرده
[Silence]
المكروه
‏anyacy
people
any
cult
of people etc ‏So based on the science
or the field in which this word is used
it has different meanings. Right? And
this happens in all languages. ‏I mean
we have this in English too, right? If
we were to say for instance
in English, if we were to use the word
heart, the heart
with doctors, what is the word heart
mean? It's the organ that pumps blood in
the chest, right? And if we were to say
heart speaking about poems and poets,
they use the word heart to mean emo
‏eng
with to
figurative sense it means the center
thrust of somethinge
of something or someone etc right so
based on the context it has different it
has different meanings different
implications
سنن الفطره
سنه
[Silence]
الختان
سن الفطره
الفطره
propend
‏time عليه
never came to people
‏Never been a propet or messenger that
would beard there never been a propet or
messenger that would grow that would
encourage people grow out their pub
that wouldourage
circumcision
even
was circumcised himself at the ag of 80
years
عليه الصلاه والسلام
صلى الله عليه وسلم منش من صحيح البخاري
بالقدوم عليه الصلاه والسلام يقول المؤلف
وعن زكريا بن ابي زائده عن مصعب بن شيبه
عن طلق بن حبيب عن ابن الزبير عن عائشه
قالت قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عشر من الفطره
عشر بالتن تنوين هذا التنوين يسمى عند
علماء اللغه بتنوين العوض
ايش تنوين العوض
يعني تعويض
يؤتى بهذا التنوين تعويضا عن حرف او كلمه
او جمله
ماشي يعني مثلا
الله عز وجل يقول
يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم الذين
كفروا زحفا فلا تولوهم الادبار
ومن يولهم يومئذ
دبره
ايش يومئذ
بمعنى يوم الزحف
لكن اختصارا بما ذكر فيؤتى بهذا التنوين
عوضا عن هذه الكلمه
ماشي فيقال ومن يولهم يومئذ اي ومن يولهم
يوم الزحف دبره
الا الى اخر الايه
وهذا كثير جدا في القران وفي السنه وفي
لغه العرب هنا يقول عشر من الفطره ايش
يعني عشر؟ يعني عشر خصال من الفطره
التنوين هنا بمعنى
عو ط عن كلمه والكلمه خصال لانه مذكر
الجمع عشر خصال من الفطره
يقول 10
الفطره قص الشارب وقد سبق ذكره
واعفاء اللحيه
والسواك
واستنشاق الماء
وقص الاظفار
وغسل البراجم
البراجم
جمع برجمه برجمه هذا يسمى البرجمه الانسان
يحت هكذا ويحت بين الاصابع هذا اسمه غسل
البراجم ونتف الابط
وحلق العانه
وانتقاص الماء يعني الاستنجاء
الاستنجاء قال زكريا قال مصعب زكريا هنا
هو زكريا بن ابي زائده المذكور في
في الاسناد قال مصعب يعني مصعب ابن ابي
شيبه ونسيت العاشره الا ان تكون المضمضه
سيد نسيت العاشره يعني ذهل عن العاشره
الا ان تكون يعني
احس او اظن انها المضمضه وهذا هو الصحيح
لما نجمع الروايه من طريق اقرانه من
المحدثين ممن سمعوا هذا الحديث عن مصعب بن
عن طلق ابن حبيب نجد انها المضمضه
secondes
have grardفاء
اللحيه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ياتي
بلفظ التوفير وفروا اللحا والعفو اعفوا
اللحا وبالاطلاق اطلق اللح
‏Alltul
beard gr how beard gr out gr out
if somebody some kind of freakishly long
beard do they grow it out to here there
was a guy back when I was studing in me
he used to come from yemen with the
scholars from there he was well known
from
حديث
معبر
would
beard on back around would come
around was
because of
in long beard right ‏And
is this the specially?
The answer is no.
هو اجماع او يكاد يكون اجماعا
بين الفقهاء
في جواز اخذ ما تطاير من اللحيه
‏some
in order to make
presentable that person trim the beard
that is you know the fers from the beard
that part of the beard which grows out
that makes the person look un makes the
person look unhygienic
صلى الله عليه وسلم
كانت لحيته عليه السلام عليه الصلاه
والسلام
صدره
‏would beard
anything
علي بن ابي طالب وعبد الله بن عباس وعبد
الله بن عمر وابي هريره وجمع
الصحابه
asم
كل ما يطلق عليه الاعثاء
والاطلاق
والتوفير يعني يقول اطلق اللحيه
مطلوقه ام لا مطلوقه لو واحد راني
ورا واراد ان يصفني
يقول هو رجل ذو لحيه صح ولا لا؟ ققول
ملتحي عنده لحيه
هذا اذا يطلق عليه عرفا ولغه
بان لحيته
مطلوقه وهذا يصح
بغض النظر عن الاطاله والقصر
‏have let the beard